what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine Nine season five episode
six today you know what to do ladies and
gentlemen ask John how he's doing to
involve him in the intro I am in fact
now
I've been involved I haven't asked you
now I'm not gonna ask you and you're not
involved in the intro
you have been excised you have been
um I'll be back
um exiled from the intro
all the intros all right guys leave a
like I'm going solo today but I'm not
leaving this side of the screen I want
there to be an empty presence the entire
time you be sure to subscribe
click that notification Bell
and also
I'm involved I'm involved in the intro
let's say guitar oh geez
full information watch long or you think
of your own copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine
how are you oh it's available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
covers several things exclusively over
their reaction house watch along is
included
okay
good so oh it's so good I'm ready let's
go oh no let's go
[Music]
follow me
nothing my mouth whoa yeah Diaz has been
checking d-holes into my mouthpiece
since we were back at the Academy check
this out
yeah Bank Shot capabilities
three points
super impressive
go long
it's playing the Avenue
[Music]
what's finally happening it's raining
Donuts like that reality yeah like that
reality Homer goes to and the time
travel episode of The Simpsons did not
get it we just came in here to tell you
to save the date because we're getting
married on May 15th we found a venue hey
hey that pressure is a big movie coming
out that day place was book solid for
the next two years but a couple fell out
of a fifth floor window we agree we
wouldn't talk about that part right
sorry it was gruesome never again the
EMT said that it was a meat pancake I'm
done
there's not much to tell other than it's
a gorgeous Mansion big old house with a
professional kitchen Chop Chop y'all a
private library for the ceremony my girl
loves books seven
bags the point is these Naturals are
going to be toys speaking of toy nips we
better get going because
an NYPD officer has gone missing the
department suspects Foul Play Oh my god
do we know the officer yes it's
it's Sergeant peanut butter
Nemesis no are you still mad at peanut
butter because he won a medal the same
day as you
of course he touched me look what you
get if you do an image search of Charles
Boyle medal of valor huh they crop me
out of my own photo oh well it uh the
screen said peanut butter the horse
that was a mistake in the editing
step it up Jesse grimwald a disgruntled
civilian admin who was recently fired by
the mounted unit if I went missing you
guys would conduct an equally thorough
search right
you should get going
could we wrap the flowers in New York
Times crossword puzzles from Key dates
in our lives oh is that something you'd
like
um
oh here's the deposit
call it the peraltiago oh good name
and the judges give it a score of
I wasn't entirely sure if you were
joking or not but
an Academy Plaza cake the groom is out
of liquor shows
these nuts may be getting too tight
the tightest morning Amanda
is today leg day legs for an hour two
hours blasting the glutes Terry's got
butt for days excuse me I said Terry's
got butt for days sexual harassment I'm
Terry you just said I had butt for days
Terry's gonna regret this are you
threatening me no no
my name is also Terry and I was talking
about my butt seems pretty arrogant
though talking about yourself in the
third person has finally Terry knows
uh
interesting beat hi Susan we're normal
people hi I was just about to call you
guys ah well no need to call because
someone else booked someone just
contacted my manager and booked the
venue before you got here but we had an
oral agreement someone just swooped in
and got it wait Susan Susan Walter who
oh the great in the palm of our hands
and then someone swooped in at the last
minute and stole it there's only one
person who would do that no but he
couldn't be oh but it is it's the
vulture yeah
what's your game here vulture huh why
are you renting our venue why do you
think meet for it so I'm getting married
really you once told me that marriage is
for women and gays
my fiance she means everything to me now
she's hot like a chick she's smart like
a guy just talking to her gives me a
Harrelson Harrelson Woody oh god look I
know I've become that gross sappy guy
but dude she's the first chick I ever
wanted to hang out with post Bang
but he does have a weak spot his woman
not that women are weak just she's our
best shot and she happens to be a woman
totally let's go talk to that spineless
skank yeah
horse is a perfect partner tough scary
and they don't show you 30 pictures of
their kid dressed as Wario for Halloween
I literally just showed you those
pictures five minutes ago really I don't
remember that
that's even worse Rosa NYPD we can see
him step away from peanut butter what's
going on you guys thought you could
catch me
I'll hit him up
is he going to save peanut butter
come on you idiot
and then he'll get no credit for doing
so
I would not stand behind a horse
just let go okay we have to force the
she vulture G Monroe to give us our
venue back so put on your game face
because we're about to stare down the
devil who's the guest
Amy it's a charity
Gene your selflessness puts us all to
shame humbled Michelle Obama
damn Jean hi can I help you she's so
familiar yeah Keith has told me all
about you he says you guys are the best
really Keith says that oh Janice that
Village needs rice double the last
shipment just take the overage out of my
paycheck
[Music]
what do you mean roadblock do I have to
fly down there and talk to the rebels
myself just get the rice to those kids
Asante Sana Rafiki
so what was the important thing you came
down here to talk about the kids and the
rice and
putting the rice
in the kids
ladies and gentlemen we have two
tuners
oh God
y'all haven't have any TM
I need to throw an ice cream party for
Terry with an eye she's a Terry and
you're a Terence who even though he's
not a child still goes by a nickname
ending in a y I mean don't people call
you Ray
how dare you
you're upset because Terry with an eye
called you arrogant and you have a
pathological need to be liked oh no I
don't I just happen to be a great person
who's naturally beloved by all despite
my personal ambivalence
you won't mind walking across the
bullpen without saying hello to anybody
no nods allowed oh
Bill what up man you were right Terry
loves to be loved
oh gosh the vulture's not the vulture
good is bad Up Is Down there's a young
Pope winter has come that reminds me of
ordering some premium cable channels
get the deposit the same ringtone
and I just got an alert my hookup app
I'm about to boink with a local signal
in my area oh he's cheating dang
I need to handle this right now I can't
believe that bastard is cheating on nice
jeans we have to save her we have to
break them up for a nice G
we break them up we get our venue back
but the main reason is to save a
wonderful person for making a horrible
mistake of course that's obviously the
point keep telling yourself that I mean
why get married at all I'll tell you why
because Jean's dad is worth a hundred
million dollars and she's his only Heir
then why did you need our thousand
dollars I mean I'm so happy we gave the
money so the kids could have Bryson Etc
oh we catfishing with Hitchcock's hookup
app then when he takes the bait we make
him end things with Gene respectfully
and gently perfect what's the sexiest
name Valerie that was fast uh she's 19
from Daytona and her job is spray Tanis
not a real word it's perfect okay Tanis
root spring break bong rips slurping
shots and crop tops that say little
cutie noise damn this girl's freaking
hot I love her already
needy guys monogamy or feminism and her
quote is whatever happened to Girls Gone
Wild
oh gotcha there he is all right we begin
with a simple hello and then we wait so
it's not to seem too aggressive no he
sent us pictures
yo I got it just said 15 more whoa whoa
wonderful We're Gonna Save jeans and
we're gonna get the Mansion back maybe
they're into this yeah maybe they're
swingers I saved that dumb horse so I'm
the hero somebody was walking by the
fire and took a picture on their cell
phone
what that's not what happened
we have footage of what really happened
Ross already called they don't want us
releasing that footage a hero horse is
good PR for the Department Hey man uh
peanut Butter's going on Ellen Ellen uh
I'm throwing Terry with a nice party
with my own money Harry with an eye
might not be an ice cream person that's
why there's a taco bar coming yes plus
barbecue yes plus a popcorn guy yes and
a vegan I think yeah there's always
going to be people in this world who
don't like you that's a fact of life I
hear you sir it's not a fact I was voted
least friendly in high school and here I
am a police captain do you know what Mr
popularity Vincent Mondale is doing
these days it's a sociologist for God's
sake sociologist Terry
if you go through with this party
I will like you less oh
Sophie's Choice you guys got it all
wrong I don't care that she's Rich look
I love her I just got spooked he put a
vulture into a cage and ah freaks out
actually vultures do very well in
captivity and they make for Life
research burn
either you break up with her or we send
her the penis pics I'll give you the
venue if you don't say anything but if
you do I'm Gonna Keep it even if she and
I break up all right I love her oh wow
the Chowder killer is back at it again
oh what is Keith like at work ah Keith
our Keith well he's a real crack up I'll
tell you that for free we have
for free hey guys potato salad
[Laughter]
someone stole from my charity and
another detective was working on the
case so hard for months and Keith came
in and solved it right away just swooped
in like an eagle
ugh
right guys yep everyone calls him
there you go
it is so nice to finally find someone I
can trust oh
oh no no no no no no no no no
a penis why yep I should have explained
it first
why
exclusive dash cam footage reveals hero
cop saved Sergeant peanut butter the
perfect partner is somebody who no
matter how much they hate you would run
through a fire to save your life whoa
all this is for me yep oh Charles Boyle
everybody
thanks guys Terry you decided not to
throw a party for Terry with an eye oh
you were right why bother trying to win
over a stranger there's so much ice
cream
I like you a lot and I always have all
right whatever
I taught him well who am I kidding Terry
needs a hug
no
the place that's available on the same
date we are getting married in a public
rec center super cheap on a basketball
court quick squeak with one working
bathroom ladies Gotta Wait
I would marry you in a dumpster oh I
would marry you in a dumpster dude the
votes are throwing an all-girl pudding
wrestling party in a mansion in May it's
the only important thing happening that
day
party
wow wow wow wow vulture my hero yeah the
role model to young men everywhere I
like to challenge you like it I liked it
would you like about it John I liked
uh lots of things but mostly it was it
was funny yeah I like the comedy like
the comedy I like the comedy I like the
comedy I liked uh the the more
specifically about the comedy was it
that uh really sing you this time um the
fact that it made me laugh and was funny
pretty funny it's effective comedy that
is the first rule of Comedy is you want
to try and make as funny as you can
and I think they clearly had funny on
their mind
and it's hard you know it's hard out
here to make comedy
slaving away in the comedy mines
plus I related to it's very relatable
episode you know
very human down to earth grounded
had a Captain Hook die
do you love me finish it or do you want
to do this he wiped his ass with the
wrong hand yeah it's been a few years
yeah it's a classic that's that's a Greg
Alba Original Classic I mean I know you
inherited it but also it's a family like
I said it's a family heirloom it's gonna
be fast from Generations
your kin will take it and carry the
torch yes absolutely
what do you like about the episode aside
from the comedy of star negatives
because we never do I thought the peanut
butter storyline was okay uh good wrap
around though it's all wrap around by
the end yeah good device especially with
the Rosa and the way how it um
pair incited with Terry's little journey
at the very end there of trying not to
be liked can't relate I never had a
struggle myself like that to this day
don't ever feel the need to be like same
never concerned whatsoever
I am all about
notoriety about the Pariah life I'm all
about being quiet and reserved and if
someone doesn't like me I go no need to
discover why or try to prove them wrong
hate comments never get to this guy not
once so go ahead leave them down below
I'll read them all unfazed they call me
a brick wall Greg
and then the second one would have to be
the Terry storyline yes that would be it
but yes
as someone who he himself has been
married and understands the struggles of
a wedding venue let's just get freak
everyone said it for like a year leading
to getting married it's what I wanted I
wanted to just elope I did not see the
point in doing a big ass wedding I even
got sick the day of and I had to get
rushed to the Urgent Care gone for hours
at my own wedding that's a real story
and
um having gone to details for specific
reasons as to why however that really
happened
further solidifying the point
[Laughter]
a bunch of people to enjoy a bunch of
[__] that I don't get to enjoy that's
what it was I think it's slap with a
three thousand dollar Urgent Care Barrel
why not yeah that's the way you go uh
but I know that's not everyone's
experience a lot of people have a good
time most people hang out a specialty
drink made for myself too came back
everyone had drink my specialty drink
didn't get to have any of my specialty
drink I was like sweet sweet day it's a
good wedding you didn't get any of the
Matrix drink where's all the vegan
cookies we ordered apparently all the
people ate all the vegan cookies no one
bother to consider maybe the groom might
want some great people attended the
wedding that day all of the grapes no
gracious people very considerate
uh my better Heavens now you are owed
like a like a like an After Shock of
just like get everything that would have
been prepared for your wedding to have
some kind of feast
that is for a reason why I got arrested
the origin oh so
um
um but now everything before that was
great uh so yeah uh finding a venue can
be a real pain in the ass and uh the
vulture I I think they had did a good
handle on the vulture him not being
changed whatsoever that he was still a
manipulative conniving dick bag I really
liked him a lot I like the vulture I I
think he's a consistent presence that
manages the joke of him never manages to
fail for me
uh on Dean Winters is just so good at
that yes yes it's cool because he plays
a guy in Power here then he plays like a
similar kind of douchebag in 30 Rock
which is another NBC show but that guy
is a loser slacker he is so it's just
funny seeing like the variations of this
guy but the same kind of cadence and
delivery uh he's really good at that
role and I I like the G Monroe girl too
yeah she looks so familiar I gotta look
her up it's bought I'm having a John
moment yeah do it I go to know I have to
go to interrupt everything because I
must know stop everything this person we
have a Google we have a Google to
complete
this is uh uh five by six I totally
typed it in the venue
season 12.
who is that one it's 12 Seasons yes who
plays Gene Monroe Maria Thayer
if they use the girl from Evil that
arrives
okay she's an accepted it's an accepted
that's the one you want to remember well
I remember
oh who is she in that yes
I don't know maybe she's just a face
you've seen a bunch yeah I mean yeah
she's on Gotham
two episodes though yeah
Scotty Mullins League
I guess she's one of those Exorcist
who's been in a bunch of stuff
she's from a town called boring
east of Portland there's a town called
boring oh it's got to be the most
interesting place on the planet yeah
it'd be shitty that's a real place yeah
let's go Boring Oregon Boring Oregon
do they have a lot of mines around there
wow it's a real place wow there's even a
sign an interstate sign
this way to boring
nice 10 exciting things to see in new
and boring work
yes oh my god there are videos dedicated
to how boring got its name dude we got a
visit we gotta shoot uh what should be
the most Wild Ride when you go there
yeah yeah it's the most like Bohemian
crazy place looks freaking gorgeous
Amsterdam yeah there's a place called
dull Is that real oh [__] which came
first dull or boring yeah I know it
actually looks freaking gorgeous here
yeah we should go do a reaction outdoors
I kind of scene before
but overall another solid episode of the
benign and it was also a good wrap
around too with them doing the riffing
back and forth all the exciting things
then they kept that same tone as they
listen to how it's all being downgraded
it's really well done good structure
she was born October 30th no year you
got to be an actress stay young forever
that's right it's Halloween that's all
you need almost almost Halloween but
yeah I like the way that unfolded and
that they just went straight for it you
know they just couldn't do it and the
vulture I like the way you played that
where it's like oh man I don't know I
kind of believe this guy but at the same
time I think he probably hasn't really
truly changed and I thought they played
the debate of that well getting you in a
position where you're like
I don't know man I don't know if I want
them to reveal this or not but it's
probably best that they did you know
she's on the cover of acceptance yeah
she's one of the lead yeah she's like
actually in that movie so like I feel
like that that has a fair shot of being
where I would recognize her from I was
being accepted a few times
glad I love your wads yeah yeah I've
seen it a few yeah I've seen accepted a
few times somehow I don't know I mean
not like recent recent but like yeah I
wound up seeing it a few times
it's one of those movies that'll come on
and then I'll be like oh yeah
then I'll leave it on
but you know it's been a while since
I've been in positions like that there's
there's less like flipping TV in this
day and age
[Music]
South Harmon Institute of Technology
[__]
alrighty guys well Brooklyn nine nine
another Case Closed leave your thoughts
down below took us five seasons for me
to say that boom I don't know why I did
not think that earlier that was a great
way to close these videos out dude
another case closed
put that no no cold cases here that's
job well done
yes you've earned yourself a drink at
the police bar
where the police go to drink after a
long day of being the police don't ruin
it Josh alrighty guys thank you for
being here we'll see you all soon
foreign